ma nouvelle caisse
le kinder surprise de mes rêves
ouais oh [ __ ]
voici à quoi je ressemble quand je fais
de la corde à sauter
c'est aussi ça avoir un chat je vais
déballer ma nouvelle paire de choses ah
bah non c'est pas la peine en fait c'est
déjà fait un cergy [ __ ] format way
back up ouest y tient
merci il paraît que les dj en concert il
stimule du coup les mecs en fait c'est
pourrait faire ça bien non supporter ça
je te fais l'amour tout le temps bon ok
on apprend mais qui n'en sais rien c'est
le syndrome de michael jackson ont
arrêté sur le rappeur nul tu parles trop
mal anglais shawa et la hype go to the
god i'm an dans mes céréales et du lait
n'est pas trop parce que prédit gère mal
le nez non on fait plutôt des blagues
aux instits qui parle arabe dit à roi
maladroit maroilles dit belgique à la
baraque à frites ce genre de mec qui
parle trop mal des meufs bondissait de
meuf est trop bonne une petite fuite des
gros seins trop trop bonne voie basse et
ma meuf
on sort ensemble depuis un mois à un
beau visage
attention imitations je suis jack
nicholson ce que les serveurs font à
chaque fois on voit tout ça pour dîner
on est deux vous êtes 2
norman norman nato et michel drucker la
normale d'un temps et mes [ __ ] de
bonnes meufs et marc michel raciste
après la victoire de l'algérie en
football c'est quoi ça c'est début d'une
émeute libère on appelle la police
manquera pas dormir assez oh non c'est
juste mes cheveux pour c'est que ce mur
est vide pourtant il ya quelque chose
normale logiciel est normal
ouais on va en boîte ce soir pour quoi
faire mais pour liquider mais tonique et
des meufs c'est une peluche
ok si tu veux si tu veux or en bois tu
me files
ce soir on tourne en boîte norman normes
le mec pas crédible qu'est ce qu'il ya
je suis un beau monde tiennent bien ta
gueule tu as construit ouais ouais c'est
ce qu'il a tort voici comment motiver un
homme à faire la vaisselle au nom tu
venais faire la vaisselle
c'est mort tu es sûr de bien skier quand
tu chantes tout seul c'est pas du tout
ce que tu crois et qui donne la personne
du roi
l'arroseur arrosé
le mec pas crédible 2 tu me prends de
vaud tu prends comme ça
ok je me bats pour voir oui je le crois
bonnier jir soit de poule
on a commencé c'est bien ensemble a
terminé ensemble offert [ __ ] mais
frères d'armes
rejoins moi chez moi
or
e